nicole kidman is no stranger to the
oscars best dressed list rocking a green
dior on the academy awards red carpet in
1997 she definitely caught the attention
of fashion fans the satin gown with the
matching bag became a major moment for
90s style
fast forward to 2003 when nicole got her
first oscar nomination for moulin rouge
the first time nominee turned heads in a
baby pink chanel
just a year later nicole became an
academy award winner dressed in a black
jean-paul gautier gown she took home
best actress for her role in the hours
and for someone that doesn't always turn
to color nicole kidman had one of her
best fashion moments in 2018 going bowls
in blue
[Music]
the award presenter had her jaws on the
floor in a dramatic timeless gown by
armani prive in a personal essay on
harper's bazaar she opened up about how
it was one of her favorite dresses she's
ever worn saying i always say i'm going
to the ball when i'm walking a red
carpet because it really does have that
cinderella quality
and what is she wearing to this year's
ball
well nicole kidman is up for her fifth
academy award nomination and based on
the last few times she was up for
hardware combined with her love for
lighter tones on the red carpets our
guess is she'll be rocking another
neutral number which designers like
saint laurent armani prive and ellie
saab have no shortage of either way with
all the oscars buzz she's been getting
the last couple of months the dress is
sure to wow us
you charged with these lessons a ton
[Music]